MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to 8.20, special relativity.
In the previous
section, we have seen
how we can look at energy
and momentum of particles
in a decay.
Here we now want to, in
collisions of particles,
create new particles.
The example, the
first example here,
is the collision of two protons
to create a proton, a neutron,
and a charged pion.
The masses are given there.
So the question now is,
what is the minimal energy
needed in order for
this process to occur
in a fixed-target experiment?
Fixed-target experiment is
we have an accelerated proton
and another proton at rest.
This might just be a hydrogen
target just sitting there.
So the question is,
how much energy--
how much do we
have to accelerate
the proton for this
process to be possible?
Now, again, stop the video,
and try to work this out.
The important part
here is to realize
that minimal energy here
means that, after the decay
or the decay after
the process occurred,
all the new particles
need to be addressed.
That is when the process
requires minimal energy.
So, instead of analyzing
this in the laboratory frame,
we want to analyze this in
the center-of-mass frame.
All right, the
momentum has to be
conserved in this discussion.
So there needs to be
some sort of momentum.
But, in the center-of-mass
frame, that's not required.
So, in that frame, the momentum
of all outgoing particles
can be 0.
And that's how we start
the discussion here.
So, in this S prime frame--
here S prime is the
center-of-mass frame--
the energy, the minimal
energy required, is 2 times
the mass of the
proton times gamma.
So here, two protons
are colliding
with the same velocity.
And that's then
equal to the energy
after this process, c squared
times the sum of the masses,
the sum of the mass of
the proton, the neutron,
and the charged pion.
And then you just have
to solve this for gamma
to find gamma equal to 1.08
or beta in this frame of 0.37.
Note, this is the gamma,
relativistic gamma,
or the velocity beta of
the protons, two protons
in the center-of-mass frame.
So we're not quite there
yet with our answer.
The answer then needs
to be boosted back
into the laboratory frame.
And we have seen how we can
do this for beta or velocities
in general.
We find beta in the
laboratory frame is 2 times--
or just result, 0.37,
over 1 plus 0.37
squared, which is 0.65.
That velocity, we can
then take and calculate
the gamma factor of the proton
in the fixed-target experiment.
All right, so we
analyzed this situation
in the center-of-mass
frame and then
did a Lorentz transformation
by just looking at the velocity
into the fixed-target frame.
So this means now, numerically,
that the proton colliding
with the proton at rest has
a total energy of this one
proton of gamma m0 c squared,
which is 0.32 times 938 MeV
over c--
MeV.
And so that results
in 1.238 GeV.
But we're interested
in the kinetic energy.
So the kinetic
energy here is given
by gamma minus 1 m0 c
squared, which is 300 MeV.
So we have to accelerate
a proton to 300 MeV
in order to be able to
have this process to occur.
All right, very similar
problem now, but here
we want to produce anti-matter.
So we have a process of proton
plus proton into three protons
and an antiproton.
Charge is conserved.
In the initial state,
the charge was 2.
In the final stage, the
charge was plus 2 as well.
OK, this works very similar
as in the previous problem.
But what we want to do here
is compare the fixed target
with symmetric collisions.
OK, so, again, the question
is, what is the minimal energy
needed in order to
produce antiprotons
in proton-proton collisions?
OK, so, exactly following
the same procedure as before,
in the center-of-mass
energy, the energy is 2 times
the mass of the protons
times gamma times c squared.
And that's 4 times the
mass of the proton.
OK, gamma prime,
so the gamma factor
in the center-of-mass
frame is 2.
Beta is 0.75.
And then we just do the
very same thing again.
We calculate the velocity
in the fixed-target frame.
And we find the velocity of
beta of 0.96 and gamma of 3.57.
So, if we compare this now,
we need a pair of 1 GeV--
remember, gamma minus 1
is the kinetic energy--
protons in a collider
experiment or 2.57 GeV
protons in a
fixed-target experiment.
OK, so you see that, in
fixed-target experiment,
in order to produce
new particles,
the energy has to be much
larger, a factor of 2.5
here in this example, than
a colliding experiment.
And that explains why we use
collider experiments in order
to test the energy frontier,
in order to produce the largest
possible energies.
And the LHC is one
example where we
have proton-proton collisions
in a circular ring where
those protons are
brought together
in symmetrical collisions.